♪ Welcome to the Hotel
California ♪
- C'est un des hotels les plus
connus du monde, et pourtant,
il n'existe pas.
♪ Such a lovely face ♪
- La chanson Hotel Calfornia,
lancée en 1977, figure dans
plusieurs listes des meilleures
chansons de tout les temps.
Elle fait partie d'un album
concept du même titre, qui est
une critique du monde musical
et de la vie de "rock star".
MIKE GAUTHIER, animateur
et journaliste musical
- La chanson Hotel California,
c'est un peu le piège
de la quête du succès, la quête
du rêve américain. Les gens
sont prêts à faire n'importe
quoi pour devenir des vedettes.
♪ And still those voices are
calling from far away ♪
GENEVIÈVE BORNE, animatrice
- C'est une chanson qui parle
de l'Amérique des années 70,
mais d'une façon plus sombre,
qui fait référence
à la décandence des États-Unis,
l'égoisme, l'égocentrisme.
♪ There she stood
in the doorway ♪
- Au coeur de la chanson,
une mystérieuse femme qui
accueille le visiteur
à l'Hotel California.
- Ce qu'on sait, en fait,
c'est que Glen Frey,
un des cocompositeurs
de la chanson, un des membres
des Eagles, s'est inspiré
d'une rupture amoureuse.
Il avait un immense chagrin
d'amour, alors cette femme-là
représente aussi cette femme
qu'il a aimée, t'sais,
puis c'est une femme qui
l'a fait souffrir.
- Une histoire personnelle
qui trouve avec cette chanson
une résonnance universelle.
- Les Eagles, dans les
années 70, c'était une machine,
des "rock stars", le machine
"rock stars", le monstre
"rock star", c'était les Eagles.
T'sais, ils avaient déjà
une couple d'albums qui avaient
été lancés, mais là, ils sont
devenus comme des méga stars
de la musique, ils sont devenus
plus des icones.
- C'est Don Felder qui a composé
la première version
instrumentale.
- Quand on dit que ça a été
une des grandes chansons d'été,
c'est peut-être normal parce que
quand celui qui a développé
l'intro à la guitare acoustique
l'a fait, il dit : "C'était
en plein coeur du mois
de juillet. Je sortais
de ma piscine. J'étais en
maillot de bain, j'étais tout
mouillé, j'ai pris
ma guitare puis j'ai commencé
à m'amuser.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Tous les éléments étaient
réunis pour qu'Hôtel California
connaisse un triomphe
et devienne un classique.
- C'est une execllente chanson,
t'sais, le refrain est hyper
accrocheur et la musique
et le fameux solo de guitare
incroyable.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Une chanson qui inspire
et qui a été reprise
de nombreuses fois : à la sauce
flamnico par les Gypsy King...
♪ Such a lovely place ♪
♪ Such a lovely face ♪
... inteprétée par Isabelle
Boulay...
♪ "Relax", said the night man,
We are programmed to receive ♪
... ou en version reggae
par le groupe Moonraisers.
♪ They livin' it up
at the Hotel California ♪
En 1994, les Eagles eux-mêmes
ont repris la chanson en version
accoustique, lui donnant
un nouvel élan.
- On voit que cette chanson-là
a quelque chose d'intemporel
qui marque à la fois son époque,
mais qui... Qu'on souhaite
entendre encore. T'sais,
elle est intemporelle
dans le sens où elle voyage
avec nous.
- Hotel California, une adresse
imaginaire qui, 40 ans plus
tard, continue d'attirer
les rêveurs.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.